charles has tested positive for
coronavirus and is now self-isolating
the prince of wales and the duchess of
cornwall attended an event held by the
british asian trust in london last night
a warning these pictures do contain
flash photography
well the chancellor rishi sunak and the
home secretary priti patel were among
the dignitaries the withdrawal couple
and they were pictured shaking hands it
was their first public engagement since
the queen expressed her wish for camilla
to be known as queen consort when
charles becomes king
on our royal correspondent ryan mills
joins me now one would imagine that the
royal family are being tested relatively
frequently rhiannon and this was a test
that he received this morning
right throughout the pandemic they have
done what they can to try and set the
right example but i think the fact that
charles and camilla were at that big
event last night mixing as they're
expected to do and i think shows that
this has kind of come out of the blue a
bit we're still waiting to find out
whether or not uh it just came about
because he was given a test and all of a
sudden
he's now realized that he's got covered
or whether he is suffering from any
symptoms or not we're still waiting for
those details from the palace but in a
tweet a short while ago they said that
the prince wales has tested positive
cover 19 and they said that he is now
self-isolating and they also say that
hrh is deeply disappointed not to be
able to attend today's events in
winchester and is going to look to
reschedule his visit as soon as possible
because of course right throughout the
pandemic the rules were restricted
really and what they could do they were
having to do lots of zoom engagements
and things like that so as soon as any
lockdown restrictions started to ease
they've been keen to get out and about
meet as many people as possible of
course with that now comes meeting more
people not wearing face masks and so in
some ways they are very exposed when it
comes to potentially um contracting
kovid 19. worth saying though we know
that the prince willis has received both
of his jabs and his booster jab and both
him and camilla have been real advocates
when it comes to pushing the vaccination
program but yet at the moment we're
still waiting to find out whether or not
he is suffering from any symptoms but
just confirm he is now
self-isolating and yeah very
disappointed that he won't be able to
carry out those engagements in
winchester today